on youtube and we should be ready to go
here in just a second let's see if this
is
live on the internet
uh let's see here where are we
i think we are live yes let's see here
live and i'm gonna go to
make sure people can see us out on the
internet
uh it is a great pleasure to have you
today roger sir roger penrose let me
just make sure we are broadcasting
to all the places we want to be
broadcasting to
yes i believe that we are i see it
we've got already 34 people are watching
there we go great okay everybody welcome
to this episode
a very special episode of the arthur c
clarke center for human imaginations
into the impossible podcast featuring my
friend
and a collaborator sir roger penrose
roger welcome to you
it's a great pleasure thank you and uh
has anything happened to you since the
last time we spoke any any news in your
life uh since
the summer it was a little thing i heard
a few weeks ago yes
yes so first i want to wish you a hearty
congratulations for
your uh your receiving of the 2020
nobel prize in physics a half of a share
of the nobel prize and i do want to talk
about that
as we as we um as we go live i do put
out slides
for this that people can find in the
youtube chat box so if people are
interested in following along
i will uh i will show some slides along
the way so i'll give you guys a couple
of seconds to get to those slides
they're in the chat and in the comments
and these are regarding
the subject of today is not going to be
sir rogers nobel prize
at first we're going to talk a little
bit about that
because i think people are curious about
it but we're also going to talk about
a wonderful book that's made a huge
impact
on me and many other people and that's
his book cycles of time
which came out in 2011 when
one of the formative books of the early
part of the last
decade that describes in some detail
auditors very curious and provocative
conformal cyclic cosmology and to
to understand it i think it's helpful to
have some preliminaries
about the uh the way that the um
the model was developed and devised and
what made you
come up with it essentially uh but first
i want to ask uh
where were you when you got the phone
call that you were a recipient of this
uh particular gilded metal here
how did you find out well it was a bit
curious because it was
a bit protracted you see i think the
first sort of
faint notice was when i was just coming
out of the shower so
but it was a call from my pa patrona
winton
and she told me she'd had this strange
message
uh and she wanted somebody wanted to
know my phone number and she said she
didn't give my
phone number out and uh
and then she sort of started to get a
little bit suspicious and she said this
is about a prize and they said no we're
not allowed to say anything
so um she phoned me up you said that's
when i was just coming out of the show
and uh and i thought um well
i have no idea what this is about but
you it's i don't see any reason why i
shouldn't give my phone number
so she did give my phone number to them
i just waited a long time and then
nothing happened
and then finally i did get a phone call
from somebody from the
academy of sciences in sweden so it
wasn't getting a little bit more
suspicious
and she didn't say what it was about but
she said that a little while the
director would front
of the academy or whatever he is was
going to phone me up
so nothing happened again and so i think
i went with something else
and then the phone did ring and i said
he did introduce himself and started
talking to me
and then he said oh you would you hang
on for a bit so i waited and i waited
and i was in my weight and then i just
hung up
if it's something important you call me
back
so he did call me back eventually and he
said it was a nobel prize yes wow
and so did you did you react honestly to
feel like it was an overdue
occasion for this or did you think that
by
endorsing my book losing the nobel prize
that you are
finally out of it i'll remind you what
you said you called it a fascinating
autobiographical account full of
intriguing detail
of the passions and inspirations that
underlie the scientific quest a highly
thoughtful and informative book
i i think this for me was the last
you're the closest i'll ever get to
having a real
not chocolate version of these but uh
but um
did you feel like it was long overdue i
mean a lot of people speculated that
your good friend stephen hawking who
we'll speak a lot about today obviously
um that he deserved a nobel prize and
that he was um
yeah he was unfairly overlooked so to
speak what were your reactions it took a
long time the
the prize says that you must give it to
someone in the preceding year
uh and you've been making contributions
every year but but
uh the award uh citation really cites
work
done perhaps many decades ago so did you
feel like it was
expected or totally unexpected how did
it how did you react to it on a personal
level
the trouble is various people had told
me that that
you know it's overdue so i had to
believe no i didn't wouldn't have
expected this at all
um apart from what people you know some
people seem to think that
i mean the work i did as you say was
ages ago it was in
actually 1964 when i did the work
paper was published in 65 and
that was at a time when the quasars had
been
where they'd been around for a bit and
people puzzling about them because they
seem to be so bright and yet so small
from the variation the timing of
variations
that they had to be of a size comparable
with what's called the schwarzschild
radius
and people knew that if anything was
that kind of size
they would collapse i mean
there was a paper in in 1949
sorry yes 1939 sorry 1939 by oppenheimer
and schneider
where they had described the collapse of
a dust cloud
and this was basically the picture of
collapse to a black hole
but people didn't take it very seriously
most particularly einstein who was in
the same
institute not even sure einstein even
read the paper
but um i think what people thought was
two things about it one was it a
collapsing dust cloud and dust has no
pressure so you might think
it's nothing to stop it the other thing
more important
is that it's spherically symmetrical so
everything simply falls in towards the
center
with nothing to stop it and so it's not
so surprising that you
would get an infinite density in the
middle and
this would be a catastrophe you didn't
know what to do with it but
people thought well that's very
unrealistic in any realistic situation
apart from the pressure which actually
works the other way pressure doesn't
help you
but apart from the pressure issue um you
wouldn't expect this thing to be exactly
spherically symmetrical so you think it
would collapse inwards get very dense
and swirl around and come swishing out
again
this was also sort of confirmed in
quotes
by a paper by lipschitz and flatnikov
two russians
who appeared to have proved that in the
general case
you would not get singularities so this
place of infinite density or
some catastrophe like that would not
happen and so it would swish around and
presumably come out again
i looked at the paper and i sort of i
didn't
notice the mistake in it there was a
mistake in the paper
but i did feel that arguments of that
sort were probably not
too persuasive to me and so i didn't
think it was conclusive
and i started thinking about visually
analyzing myself
being inside a collapsing collection of
material
matter and i more or less came to the
conclusion
that you couldn't prove anything just by
local argument
it had to be something global something
more
not in one place but in the sort of some
surrounding region
and this was a key thought that it was
something non-local
and later on i came to this there's a
story which i told people often
about when i was talking to ival
robinson who was
an englishman who worked in relativity
theory
in dallas texas mostly and he was
visiting back
home in his home country and talking to
me
and he was somebody who had the real
gift of the gab i mean
artistically i mean he was he was a
wonderful speaker
and he was just talking to me i don't
know what about
and then we got to this side street
where we had to cross the road
and the conversation stopped him across
the road and then we got to the other
side it started up again he told all the
and all sorts of
exciting things he was telling me about
then he went home i went off somewhere
and i came away thinking having this
strange
feeling of elation and i couldn't think
why i felt like that so i went through
all the things that happened to me
during the day
what what i had for breakfast and what i
did after that and did i have a walk or
catch the tube or you know obviously
caught the tube
but um well it was and then eventually
working through all the things that
happened
i got to this time when we crossed the
street now i realized in that time
crossing the street i had an idea
which was i think the idea of what i
call a trapped surface
that's what's called a trap surface
which is a surface
i can actually describe what it is you
think of a surface
an ordinary two-dimensional surface and
it's closed up
so it's like a spherical surface it
doesn't have to be a sphere but
imagine it's closed up and that surface
you imagine a flash of light
occurs on that surface now normally if
you have a flash flood on the surface
if the surface is bendy it'll it'll be
concave on one side and complex on the
other
and the concave side the light will be
converging
on the other side it'll be diverging but
in this curious case when you get
in this beyond this point of no return
it's what we now would call
inside the horizon but when you're
at that stage you can find surfaces
where the flash of light both the inward
flash and the outward flash
are converging so the light rays are
coming together on both sides
and i knew that this would be bad news
from studies that i'd done previously of
looking at
future sets you look at the house set in
space time you see what
region can you reach by um
time-like curves that is particles which
don't travel faster than light what kind
of
region do they sweep out and what's the
boundary of that region and what's it
look like
and what is it generated by light rays
and what the light rays do and how do
they
reach their caustic surfaces and
crossing regions and so on
and i was familiar with that and i
realized that when you had this
situation
you're gonna have trouble you would
there's no real way i mean there are
various sort of loopholes but no serious
loopholes
as long as the energy density doesn't go
negative or something like that
you would definitely have to have a
singularity
and so this was the paper i wrote this
paper and said
uh the tune singularities were necessary
in it collapse
the main point about this is that you
don't make any assumption of symmetry is
you can break the symmetric case and
then wiggle it around
as long as you don't wiggle it hugely so
it's qualitatively fairly similar
but doesn't mean that the matter has to
fall in towards the center it can be
quite complicated any in any way you
like as long as it starts
starts in this sort of converging state
and then it necessarily has you get a
singularity
i had a slightly awkward point in the
proof which charlie misner
improved later on so it was um
i want to ask you about that in terms of
uh collaboration
et cetera but uh but first before we get
to that so i'm showing a slide from
a picture from cycles of time
where you describe this in fall into the
singularity
this summer you know uh you were you
were quite busy this summer maybe in
uh anticipation your your uh your your
third eye or something
knew that you were going to be very busy
and and i do want to take the time to
to uh to appreciate you and to recognize
and express gratitude for being on the
show in such a hectic time
uh you have to prepare your your nobel
lecture etc
but i was um inviting you over the
summer and it just the timing didn't
work out for you to be on our podcast
discussing
theories of everything with our guests
uh
we ended up having quite a lovely
series of guests this summer and and we
were
entranced by these ideas about theories
of everything
and how they could perhaps unify quantum
quantum mechanics with gravity and a lot
of what i took away from
that discussion was kind of a new doubt
that
singularities exist and not to be offend
you in any way but
we have no physical evidence of a black
hole singularity
um and the converse process we'll talk
about uh you know
you talk about falling into the black
hole and what you would see once you
pass the event horizon
with all the light cones tilting towards
the singularity and all paths
uh all world lines will terminate on the
singularity but
um are singularities also a matter of
faith
that a physicist must have or do we have
any evidence of anything
in nature that is physically infinite uh
in any regard that we have
evidence for i think the answer to that
question is
we have well we have things in
aerodynamics where you get
shock waves and so on i mean but then
you say the physics that you've been
using at some point you have to replace
by
more refined physics and so the idea
here and this is what i
certainly stated in the paper was that
maybe
you have to consider quantum gravity
that quantum mechanics
classical theory of general relativity
which is a
classical period of gravity um doesn't
uh combine with quantum mechanics and so
when the densities get enormous you
might expect the quantum effects would
start to become important
density is getting or the curvatures
become enormous
and so the classical description would
become inappropriate
no it's quite prepared to accept that
but
in a sense well you see i i tended not
to use the word singularity in most of
the discussions
i'm not quite sure i remember what i
said in that particular paper it was in
the title but
i don't know whether i'd certainly
considered other possibilities like
the last people in the chat room can you
look up the title of somebody post that
in the chat uh for sir roger because i
forgotten it too yes
i think he's in the title yeah so
somebody out there please we have
hundreds of people
listening right now so somebody will
post it in the chat room for us
yes gravitational collapse and
space-time singularities
actually i can't remember because i've
written so many pages just 400 by my
count roger it's
but not on its subject other subjects
yes but you see it was more stephen
hawking when he started working on the
cosmological singularity that he tended
to use the word singularity
and i think he more or less converted me
to using it later
it's just a useful term it's a
singularity in the classical theory
but it doesn't mean that physics gives
up it might be that the physics does
something
probably more where quantum mechanics is
playing a more important role
so i was quite prepared to believe that
in fact that was the sort of view i had
but that led to other things you see
i've been trying to work on this nobel
lecture you see and there are
two two sides to it one is what led up
to it
that that singular that paper basically
and what grew out of the paper is the
second part
and what grew out of it and
i mean there's i can sort of go through
it if you like
um first of all well stephen hawking
picked up on the
techniques i was using i should say that
i i gave the first
time i talked about this was a lecture i
gave in king's comic college london
and in the movie you see stephen hawking
sitting in the audience with sparks
coming out of his head of inspiration or
whatever it is
the trouble with this was he wasn't
actually there right
i mean hollywood got something wrong
factually and science
it's not quite so bad because denis
sharma who was a
good colleague and friend of mine who
was in cambridge at the time
and he uh he he educated me a lot on
physics he was a
crucial person in my education in
physical sciences particularly um
rarity and other things too and he
uh asked me if i'd give a repeat talk in
cambridge
and i said sure and in january early
january i gave a talk
i think it was early january uh and
stephen hawking was
that talk it was a repeat of the one in
london is that when you met him for the
first time roger
that's what i meant yes it wasn't just
the he was president in the audience
because i had a special session with him
and
and george ellis i see probably brandon
carter i can't remember but george ellis
was certainly there
and we talked about the details of the
argument i'd used
they were looking at something not
nearly so general is that what i was
doing
and then stephen picked up very quickly
on these arguments and used the version
of my theorem in the opposite direction
in time
to to prove a result in cosmology
but it was not a terribly strong result
and he
developed the techniques considerably
beyond what i had done and
eliminated many of the loopholes and
applied it to
cosmology as well as to black holes and
then later on we got together and wrote
a paper which more or less encompassed
the results which we'd done before
um but you see stephen picked up on the
sort of black
the big bang end of it and an important
thing you see about general relativity
in
most physics is that it's symmetrical in
time
the theory works one way just as well as
it works the other way
so if you expect to get singularities
when matter is collapsing in the future
you would expect to get singularities
the other way around
when matter is diverging away
from a very dense state in the past this
is the
picture of the big bang and the question
is this is generic thing too i mean can
you
perturb it in some way and maybe get rid
of the singularity so you might imagine
instead of having a big bang which was
the beginning
you might have had a previously
collapsing phase
which somehow swirled around in a
complicated way and then came swishing
out again
now the next stage in the story
was when i was
you know i think it was i was in
princeton again i should say i was in
princeton
when the quasar things were getting
there and so i was
worrying about the well i wasn't
actually in princeton when i thought of
the theorem but it was
just a little after that but i was pre
in princeton again and they used to have
these meetings in stevens institute in
hoboken new jersey
which was a short drive from princeton
and many people
used to go there and they would go there
from other universities in new york
state
and they were it was a good place for
getting together thinking about things
in
relativity that was mainly to do with
that and one of the cars
i i i i noticed that one of the cars
that could have taken me up there was
was full but in the car was
james peebles jim peebles who was the
previous
physics snowboarder i mean
last year but i saw when he was there i
took my opportunity i said
um you cosmologists i mean there are
many many
cases where you can get singularities
and models and they could expand from
singularities and all sorts of
different kinds of moles why don't you
consider these in cosmology and he
looked at me
and he said because the universe is not
like that
i thought gosh i can't i assume he meant
by
evidence from the cosmic macro
background you see this very uniform
radiation coming with all very very tiny
variations in temperature
and this is pretty good indication of
how very very uniform
the big bang was so i thought my gosh
it's very very different and this sort
of bugged me for a long time
you have the singularities and collapse
which are very complicated and
hugely diverging i should say something
now about the kind of
physics or the kind of curvature you get
in space-time
in four-dimensional space you can have
two kinds of curvature one of them is
called the ritchie curvature
riccci and the other is called the vial
curvature w-e-y-l
now it
it kind of worked hard done earlier in
looking at spinners and general
relativity which is an important
motivational thing
in my case you can see very easily that
the
thing splits into these two parts now
the richie curvature
is directly what's given by the matter
so you have a
matter density and that gives you just
there where the matter is
richie curvature now when you don't have
any
richie curvature there's the other kind
which is the vile curvature
now vile curvature describes the
gravitational field
i mean this is the way it wasn't
necessarily the way most people looked
at it they tend to think of the metric
as giving the gravitational field
but the curvature that describes free
gravity or gravitational waves
or the gravitational field in the same
way that as in electromagnetism you have
the electromagnetic field
and you have the sources which are the
charges so the charges are the analog of
the richie tensor
and the electromagnetic field that's the
analog of the vial tensor
and it's important to get this
distinction now
in the early universe you get very very
big concentration
of matter that's richie curvature
but what about the vile curvature now
you see
i began to realize and this is a big
factor in in
the whole discussion is this difference
between the type of singularity you get
in the
past that's the big bang or in the
future when black holes
is um well the curvature
is very different but the other point of
importance
is this very very important principle
in physics or the what's called the
second law of thermodynamics
now the second law of thermodynamics
tells you
that entropy now entropy is a sort of
measure of randomness
think of it as just a measure of
randomness the entropy
increases with time that's the second
law of thermodynamics i mean it might
have little fluctuations where sometimes
it goes down but the general trend
is it increases with time now
well an important factor in this is the
work done by beckenstein and hawking
where they showed that there is an
entropy
assigned to a black hole and this
entropy is proportional
to the surface area of the horizon of
the
i think it's important first of all i
don't think i just made this point
earlier
that people got very confused in the
early days
about the horizon and the singularity
because the way that schwarzschild
originally wrote
it down the solution of einstein's
equations which described
the spherically symmetrical body the way
he wrote it down
is you have this place where the
things seem to go haywire and this is
called the schwarzschild singularity
now this singularity if you think of the
sun for example
and you imagine squashing it down you
see the
the schwarzschild solution applies to
the vacuum outside the sun
but within the sun you've got matter and
so that particular solution
doesn't apply you have another one short
she'll have another solution which
people don't take very seriously but
the main point is that you have a
different solution when there is matter
so outside you get zero and that's what
we normally call the schwarzschild
solution
is the outside of the sun's body well
say yeah say the sun now suppose you
imagine that the sun contracted
to smaller and smaller without any
radiation or anything coming out
if it were to contract then you have the
great a bigger region of vacuum
and a more concentrated region of matter
now if you could
squash it right down until i forget a
couple of kilometers or something i
forget
well that was directed exactly you get
to this structural
so-called singularity people thought oh
that's just nonsense and you get
you can't deal with it but various
people
realize one of the most important of
these was
lametra who is a very important
cosmologist
he was a he was a priest a belgian
priest
and he um discovered solutions
uh on the answer well there was friedman
originally but
lemaitre um looked at the big bang and
he was a big promoter of the big bang
and he had was the people person who
really i guess persuaded einstein you
had to take these things seriously
but uh he also realized that if you
sort of let mata fall in it could cross
through
this region which used to be called the
schwarzenegger singularity
and it's not a singularity it's what we
now call a horizon
so this is a region where mata can fall
in and once it's got
through this region it can't get out
again so it's a
sort of one-way trapdoor or something it
gets through the surface and
there's no escape and in the spherically
structural symmetrical model that
friedman and
and um rock remembers talking about
cosmologies
so that um that lametra had you see
you you have this picture of a black
hole and the oppenheimer and snyder
later on had this collapsing dust cloud
which was the same sort of picture
and you can see in both those models
that the
horizon that the what's r equals 2n this
is the
in the sort of units that's used in
relativity theory r is the radius
m is the mass and when the radius
reaches
twice the mass in these curious units
then you get to this radius but it's not
a singularity it's a horizon
verizon meaning you can fall through it
but you can't get back out again or
light can't get out again that's the key
point
light can fall in light thinks it's
going out
but it's actually falling in if you like
as it goes through the horizon
and the pictures you like that i like to
draw we have these cones yes
i'm showing that on the screen i have
the slides and remind people they can
download the slides
and the link i'm putting in the comments
and chat uh you can get these very
slides and i'm showing not only the
black hole
conformal space-time diagram but also
the white hole which as you say
violently i mean this is as violent as
sir roger gets it says violently
disobeys
the second law of thermodynamics and so
i want to understand that so yes keep
going
i'm showing the picture as you're
speaking sir roger
yes we see the the black hole
by this hawking beckenstein hawking
foreign has a sort of
general physical argument to show that
the
surface area of this horizon would be a
measure of entropy
but he didn't know exactly the formula
then stephen hawking had a much more
refined argument
to show exactly that the entropy
was given by this area a quarter of the
area in appropriate units
and this turns out to be an absolutely
stupendous value
so if you consider now with the sort of
sizes of black holes we know are out
there
the amount of entropy in the current
now and now in the current universe is
almost entirely in black holes
by an absolutely enormous factor
now i was aware of this enormous factor
and don page who used to
i used to talk to quite a bit he looked
after stephen hawking quite a bit when
he was
i think dawn was a graduate student at
that time but dom was very good with the
figures you could ask him something like
this and we'd come up with a precise
figure
and he just told me how enormous
this entropy was in these black holes
and
this made it clear that when you get
clumping of material and the material
clumps more and more
and finally it produces black holes this
is a
you can see this is the second law in
action
now it's curious the way gravity behaves
it's rather
you see it's misleading in many ways
people think of a gas in the box or
something like that
and you might have a gas which is in one
corner of the box with some kind of
compartment and you release the gas and
it spreads out through the box
now that's an increase in the entropy so
you have a
an irregular distribution of gas which
is a low entropy state
and then it spreads out through the box
and this is getting to a higher entropy
state so as
the gas spreads out through the box the
entropy is increasing
now that's the sort of picture you get
with a lot of materials and so on
but gravity is the opposite you have
things
spread out and that is low entropy and
then when the
material clumps together that represents
increasing entropy
so the picture is sort of the opposite
but nevertheless it's still the second
law
to get uniformity to clumping
and we live off it i mean forget about
the black holes
the sun's out there and that used to be
just a distribution of gas spread out
uniformly
and as it clumped together you've got
this hot spot
in the dark sky and that gives us
the entropy which we live off life
schrodinger wrote a book called what is
life and he was the first person ready
to point this out
this distribution this
disparity between the hot spot of the
sky
which is the sun and the cold dark sky
is what we live off yeah so you get
photons from the sun which are high
frequency
and there are relatively small number of
those photons
and then the infrared photons which
escape back out into space
carrying essentially the same energy
that comes in
so we don't get energy from the sun this
is a misleading thing people think
we don't get energy from the sun because
the energy just goes back out again in
the night
but it goes back out in a high entropy
form
because there are many many more photons
taking the energy out
that came in from the sun because the
frequency going out is lower
and by planck's famous formula you need
more of them to cavities carry the same
energy
and therefore more degrees of freedom
and therefore there's more entropy
so they that carries the entropy away
and we get the sun as a source of low
entropy that's
the key point that schrodinger made and
i want to point out sir roger just uh
just to stop you for a second
so there is um that you can buy a copy
of what is live erwin schrodinger's book
and the forward is written by none other
than sir roger penrose
so you guys are linked together uh both
electronically and intellectually and by
this prize here that i have to resist
eating all the time but go on to roger
yeah so we live on the on this
differential and entropy
and energy uh not the energy and heat
from the sun but instead from this
different large differential and
processing of entropy correct
exactly that's right and that was
schrodinger i've always been a great
admirer of schrodinger he's one of my
great
i'm a great fan of him i learned general
relativity from
of all really how did that come about no
he has this little book called
space-time structure oh i
i'm not familiar with it okay i'll have
to look at it
you can ignore the last chapter where he
goes on to some unified view of there
but everything else
and he just he just described these
things in a nice friendly way i was like
would you say that that influenced you
sorry to interrupt roger but would that
influence you in your pursuit of
the soft and wet world in other words
consciousness that later drove you into
learning about consciousness would that
be attributable to schrodinger
that's a complicated story
i would say not so directly no but i
mean
in a certain way i certainly had been
influenced by
and that book in particular yeah but so
getting back to the white holes and
and the black holes analogy how does it
violently disobey
the second law of thermodynamics to have
a white hole after all wouldn't that be
analogous to the
big bang singularity that uh hawking and
you and others have worked on
well you see it has a big entropy it
still has the same forking entropy
um about this entropy is
high so you see if it's
if it were to evaporate away you see
imagine that collapse through a black
hole
or the white hole would expand out to
become
a distribution material and that would
be a huge reduction in entropy
so it goes violently as i said i suppose
against the second law
because if you simply reverse the
collapse to a black hole you have
you have a relatively small entropy to
begin with
on in the material which goes enormously
up
as soon as it crosses the horizon and
the entropy goes absolutely shooting up
so you have the opposite behavior which
is just dreadfully against the second
law
now you may say second laws people you
often say oh it's just a
statistical thing and so it's not so
fundamental but
well i think i don't i think it is very
fundamental
it's fundamental because really
because what started it off and what
started it off was the fact that there
were no white holes in the beginning
we had no vile curvature you see
i put this hypothesis this is just a
hypothesis
like everybody else at the time i
thought you had to describe
singularities by quantum gravity
and so yeah i was certainly of that view
that you think the why you sort of
resolve the singularities in black holes
or how you resolve it would be through
some kind of quantum gravity nobody
knows what the correct theory is but
that would be how you do it now how
would that singular how
that theory applies in the big bang well
maybe it resolves that singularity and
maybe gives you a bounce instead of a
explosion but the nature of the
singularity since my sort of
brief conversation with jim peebles in
the back of the car
i had to get in another car it was full
but
that persuaded me that the universe
started on this very strange
low entropy initial singularity
and it's low entropy in gravity not in
the matter
the matter seemed to be pretty well
thermalized as much as you could have
as far as one could see that's not where
the the low entropy resided
low entropy resides in the fact that the
gravitational degrees of freedom
were not activated and this is what i
sort of
postulated as what i call the vile
curvature hypothesis
that is the past type singularities like
the big bang
for some reason had to be zero
vowel curvature the singularities in the
future black hole singularities
would be wildly diverging infinite
biocurvature and the matter might have
even been wiped out by them
so perhaps it's almost entirely in viral
curvature at that point
and this is a huge discrepancy between
the two types of singularity and at that
time i thought well this tells us that
quantum gravity whatever it just must be
a really really odd theory
so all right i thought it was an odd
theory but maybe
this all tied in with sort of beliefs i
had that somehow gravity was
responsible for the collapse of the wave
function
you see and that was a view
which i still hold but not in quite the
same way
because i don't think the the quantum
gravity
is really what's responsible for the big
bang singularity
so so that's uh that's provocative as
well and that actually
connects to this conversation that we
had over the summer with er
eric weinstein sabian hossenfelder we
had lee smallin your friend lee smallin
and and uh for a bit we had lisa randall
before she cut out
but we we had this discussion as to
whether or not there really is a need
for quantum gravity and to keep beating
on a dead horse or even to
is there a need for a theory of
everything in other words is it
if god i know you and i have talked
about god on previous podcasts but just
stipulate for the
time being that which you get by playing
around with the schrodinger equation
and doing something different from it
from
evolving the schrodinger equation
evolving according to the schrodinger
equation
so you suddenly throw the schrodinger
equation out the window pull in
something else
gives you probabilities wheel that out
the out the door again and bring it
up back in through the window to shred
your equation and go ahead back again i
mean it's completely
inconsistent what you do now all sorts
of people worry about this some lots of
physicists don't they say well we just
take the theory as it is
when we make a measurement we do what
we're told and so on and that's fine it
works well
people who do quantum mechanics in some
practical way always do that
people who are more philosophically
minded worry more about what really
happening
they might say well things get so
complicated you can't very well use the
schrodinger equation
and you do something else if you look
carefully at what you do when you do
something else you see it's cheats at
some point
it always cheats it has to cheat because
schrodinger equation doesn't say you get
alternative problems is
it says you get this complicated state
which involves stupid positions of
different alternatives
so that's uh that's the the
measurement problem the quantum
interpretations foundations
so but is it true that you know i heard
it once said maybe it was uh
another one of your um co-laureates who
said something like
quantum mechanics needs interpretations
like birds need ornithologists
in other words we love to have you know
kind of a neat way of describing but i
know for sure that
richard feynman a definite co-laureate
of yours
said something to the effect that uh
that you know the word is not the thing
and and being able to for us to
understand it it just means that there's
a lacuna
in our uh way of describing it and even
if we can describe it satisfactorily
that doesn't mean we truly understand it
the fact that we can
write down classical you know general
relativity doesn't necessarily
mean that we truly understand it because
it would have things in it
necessarily so but i think one crisp
question for you is what if there was no
singularity
with that but it was a very dense object
extremely dense you know denser than
anything that we can imagine but not
truly
infinitesimal in extent would that
affect
the observables in any of your theories
of black holes or
as we'll come to later in triple c
well you i mean it doesn't make much
difference you see
because we're not going to see the
singularities and you can
travel into i mean it wouldn't be you
take one of these really big super
massive black holes you could probably
take a spaceship go into it i don't know
how long probably a year maybe that's
where the details are you could have you
could play cards or you could
try and work out how what the space time
is doing out there and you
observe things outside you would look at
the universe outside
you could have a decent time this time
of life for a while and then
curvatures start to get so big that you
get ripped to pieces
but still you wouldn't know what
happened to singularity because you just
run into it
you wouldn't see any any other
singularities
certainly if cosmic censorship is
correct in the in the sense i like to
see
you wouldn't even see any of the other
singularities i mean
i it's it's wrong to think of it as a
point really that that's one of the
things when you look at the
prophetical structure of things the
singularity is really a
space-like region which you run into but
um that doesn't matter too much it's uh
funny because we'll have on a friend of
yours hopefully in a little bit
uh jenna levin has agreed to come on
just to wish you a
a hearty congratulations later i'm
hoping to patch her in on this phone
call
but she's written a book that comes out
next week called black hole survival
guide i'm showing it on the screen here
so it could be very practical i'll ask
her i will ask her when she comes on
how long it will take and what she will
do on the way down but
please continue well she's been looking
at that that's nice yes
yeah no you have quite a bit of time you
could certainly you could certainly
do a lot of observations as you fall you
couldn't communicate with your friends
yeah you won't you won't publish it but
um that wouldn't be much good though
but uh um no unless you see there were
wormholes and then of course you have to
violate energy
and all that sort of stuff but um never
mind
no it doesn't matter that much in a
sense
except you know as you say you said it
before i mean why do we need to know
is it just we we like to know what's
happening because we like to know what's
happening not because it's any use to us
well i guess that applies to lots of
things in
in astrophysics and so on you might see
what was it
recently a magneton was it yes
just the other day somebody had i mean
that's good fun and you might
work it out and so on but you're not
likely to go and see it um
no the point is the different one which
i hadn't really got down to
the argument i'm making is that we need
a theory
which combines general relativity in
quantum mechanics
and that we really need if we want
coherent description of the world in
many ways
we need that theory which combines
generality and quantities but it won't
be
what people think of as a quantum
gravity theory that it's not quantum
mechanics which
rules it's it's they both
have to rule in in some kind of uh
union the thing is that
the problem with quantum mechanics is
i'm trying to say is this reduction of
the state or
collapse of wave function whatever you
want to call it which seems to go
against
unitarity they go against the
schrodinger equation you have to have
something else
and either you have to know the sort of
routes that people take maybe it's
consciousness which has
different laws i'm sure that doesn't
resolve the measurement problem
i mean i've always you could imagine for
example
some distant planet on which there is an
atmosphere something like the earth's
atmosphere and we know about things like
butterfly effects
that the actual atmosphere depends on
tiny little
effects it's a chaotic system and
it depends ultimately probably on
quantum effects
now you see this space probe
is going out to this distance several
light years away
and it wants to take a photograph of the
atmosphere of this planet now there's no
life on that planet
it's it's an earth-like planet but
there's no life on it so there are no
butterflies
where it doesn't i mean there could be
butterflies but there are there are no
conscious observers and so according to
the consciousness it reduces the state
theory the atmosphere will be some
complete
quantum mess of superpositions of
different atmospheres
it's a wuge okay the the probe sends
this
pictures of this whoosh back to the
earth and it takes a few light years and
then somebody is sitting
in front of a computer screen looking at
this whoosh
as soon as the picture comes on the
computer screen because that's a
conscious being looking at it
suddenly it can reduces into one
atmosphere or another
this to me is complete absurdity even
more absurd than shows of his cat
it's telling us that there is something
wrong with the view that it's
consciousness that reduces the state
so i don't think it's that i do however
have this crazy view that it could be
the other way around
that whatever is involved in the state
reduction
which i believe to be a physical process
which is going around all over around us
the stage is being reduced all over the
place
it's reduced when you get enough mass
displacement
so it's not just a dead cat and a live
cat you have two
configurations which differ sufficiently
it doesn't have very much
and you can see how much it is from the
calculation
it doesn't have to be very much and then
it reduces to one or the other
so this reduction is a physical process
which takes place spontaneously
there doesn't have to be any conscious
being looking at it
or even anywhere close it just does it
itself
according to some law which involves
both gravity and quantum mechanics
which we don't have yet although it's
possible to make estimates
using principles of general relativity
mainly the principle of equivalence
which is the
principle of galileo and einstein
that free fall cancels out gravity
so the rocks falling from the leaning
tower of pisa if they ever were
would be fall together as though there
were no gravity
and galileo gives a wonderful
description of fireworks you see a
fireworks goes up and you see this
beautiful
spherical thing falling just as though
there was no gravity
and he uses this description in his
books
i i find that really wonderful yeah so
you you well appreciated that you could
cancel gravity out by falling freely
and then einstein takes this further to
say yes this is a
fundamental principle gravity is not a
force it's something
more subtle than that you can cancel it
out locally what's
interesting is how that force varies
from place to place and this is where
you get into the vial curvature
the vinyl curvature tells you one of the
ways in which you can vary
as you move from place to place
so what i'm saying is that this
principle is inconsistent with the
principles of chronic pain
you can do a little calculation and you
can see that if you take the principle
of equivalence
it is inconsistent with the
normal principles of quantum field
theory but if you see if you can cancel
a gravitational field field with
with free fall then it gives you a
different vacuum than you do if you
if you don't free fall and this gives
you if you have it different free falls
in different places you have a problem
with
quantum field theory and you can
estimate how big that problem is
and that gives an estimate of how
quickly a quantum state will reduce
in terms of how much mass you've
displaced between the two states
and that while curvature is a purely
classical object
correct yes and so
um how does it play a role maybe we can
move to um
uh talking about uh well i want to
finish uh this discussion of
um of black holes and especially
of what happens with the so-called
hawking radiation that will eventually
become important when we talk about
uh when we talk about conformal cyclic
cosmology can i get from you
uh what how did you react when when
stephen came to you and when you learned
about
hawking radiation this was in 1970 so
how did you react did you say i wish i
thought of that
no it was more like this i can tell you
the story no i simply heard
whether i heard a room over i think i
phoned up dennis i can't remember
i i i think i've been away somewhere and
i called dennis up
and and they said what's new i can't
remember exactly what it was he said
wasn't it
so have you heard there's the stephen
hawking tells you that black holes
actually radiate and so on and i said
what
and so i phoned stephen up and i phoned
him up and he
described it to me and it was um
i think there were two questions one is
i ask what happens to the the black hole
because the
radius can't get smaller without
negative energy so he said well in
quantum field theory
you can violate the energy conditions
which i knew already so i said oh i see
it's that
okay but then he said um
i can't remember in which order but then
he said it's
very good to have an entropy no to have
a temperature attached to black hole
because that makes sense of the formula
that he well steven and brandon carter
and
and jim bardeen i think it was just
three of them there may be
another author they'd written a paper in
the analogies between black hole
dynamics and thermodynamics
and you had one thing corresponds to
this thing and
the thing that was missing in this
analogy was the temperature
you see everybody thought black holes
didn't have any temperature
they have to be absolutely cold
and i didn't know if you weren't worried
by that so i i think i did think of the
entropy who did apply to the black hole
but stephen thought it was merely an
analogy and then he
until he did his calculation to show
that there was a temperature
and therefore it wasn't just an analogy
it could be real
and so then he told me this it fits in
with the formula and say ah
okay that's fine so so no i was
convinced already
in that phone conversation but i hadn't
thought of it no i thought
i thought if you make sense of the
thermodynamic analogy which i really
believed already
that that would the temperature had to
be there
i hadn't predicted this at all so i was
surprised about it but
in in view of this conversation i was i
was happy with it
reasonable
[Laughter]
and what do you make of the connection
between black holes
and the origin of the universe as we
turn towards uh conformal cyclic
cosmology now
i want to get your opinion about how it
is possible
that such you know two completely
different on the face of it
uh events and so forth are a phenomena
have at their core potentially
interwoven
uh aspects and even in the case of both
hawking radiation and conformal cyclic
cosmology
they have uh much to say about not only
the beginning of the universe
potentially but the end of the universe
uh in terms of what will remain uh many
eons
from now so why why is it that a black
hole
would play a role in uh in the future
of of the entirety of our universe
well you see this yeah i mean i was
i remember thinking how boring the
universe is going to be
you see because okay you get these black
holes they're pretty exciting for a bit
but then you get rather bored with them
after a while
they swallow entire galactic clusters
that's the likely likely thing
superclusters will disperse from each
other but individual clusters
will ultimately be swallowed by
well various black holes and they
swallow each other you see and then
there's some final
king of black holes which just sits
there
and it sits there and it sits there now
that's pretty damn boring
but what's really boring is you have to
wait for
well something like i guess don page
told me 10 to 103 years or so more than
a google year a thousand google
years or something you have to wait till
the biggest of these black holes
finally finally finally decide to
evaporate away completely and disappear
with a pop
something like that and then it's dead
boring
absolutely dead boring so i thought gosh
this is boring
and then well who's going to be bored by
this mostly photons they're just running
around
protons running around and it's very
hard to bore a photon
not simply because photons don't have
any experiences
but because the time from the creation
of any photon until infinity is nothing
people often argue it the same way they
say times freezes or something it's the
wrong way around
time flips by enough
it's nothing so they're in no time
experience at all
with for that photon the entire universe
flashes by
until it gets to infinity and goes
through
to the other side now why do i say goes
through the other side because in the
early days when i said the early days
in the 1960s where people were playing
around with
gravitational radiation and trying to
work out how you work out the energy
carried away in gravitational waves and
so on and bondi and
sax and people had wonderful formerly
for this
and i said i thought of a better way of
looking at it from my point of view
you take a conformal map and you squash
infinity down
to a sort of boundary now what is a
conformal map
i think a very good illustration of this
is one of these escher
pictures there's a famous one called um
i think it's circle limit four yes i'm
showing that yeah
i'm showing that on the screen for our
listeners angels in the devil yes yes
the angels the devils and the
three-dimensional model that you have of
it
in the book it's real yes i'll show that
yes
go on sir roger three different
geometries you can have uh
uh to
two-dimensional surface well take the
the circle limit that's the angels and
devils
seeming to crowd themselves more and
more together towards the edge of the
picture
now as far as these angels and devils
are concerned you have to imagine that
their geometry they're not getting
squashed towards the edge
they are the same size and shape as the
ones in the middle
and this is a conformal representation
which means angles
are correctly depicted right up towards
the edge
so if you looked at the angle on the
devil's wing say
that would be exactly the same as
closest you could get to the edge or the
shape of the
devil's eye pretty well is the same
right
small shapes are correctly represented
even though they look smaller
the what's called the conformal oh
we've run out of time so we can oh no no
it's uh i have um just have john 11 on
the line uh
i'm trying to bring her out janna can
you hear us
my screen is going blank oh no can you
see me
i can see you in the corner but okay oh
it's okay i still see you
um trying to ring john 11 here to get
her
on uh jenna are you there
i can't see you i can't hear you let me
uh keep going
actually sir roger while i'm working on
this can you hear me i can hear you
but you're small oh okay yeah don't
worry about my size for a second yeah
i see here yeah okay so janna's here now
there's a question that i find really
interesting uh from
a listener named church of entropy the
question is is it possible i'll read you
the question how is it possible to have
a universe with singularities
that also has conformal the ability to
make conformal
mappings don't they exclude you know
doesn't uh the existence of it even a
singularity preclude the existence of
conformal mappings
no let me i i don't know if i can get
your picture back because it's
somehow it's just let me see hold on
does this work um
can you see me now no
roger do you see me at all if you click
on the picture
do you hear me if i click on the little
picture yeah if you click on the little
picture it should make it bigger
nothing got bigger but then it went
small again yeah
um
let's see okay i can still hear you and
i can see you so
i think that's yeah i think that's the
important thing if
as long as you can see me i can see you
uh even if it's small don't worry about
it being small
roger it's not that's not important yes
i think you're looking awfully small
that's what it is yeah
okay yeah don't worry about that yes um
oh singularity when you see conformal
geometry is actually something i used to
be interested i think i played around
with it when i was an undergraduate even
before maybe
you can think of it in the plane you see
it's you see in the plane you think of
uh projective geometry if the straight
line is the dominant thing
and if you you know think of a picture
you project a figure onto a plane
and straight lines remain straight lines
that's projective geometry
like a formal geometry is something
where angles are preserved
and you can have conformal geometry
oh jana i think i lost sir roger let me
see
everybody please bear with us as we're
trying to get sir roger
connected with jen 11 hopefully
he will pick up the phone the skype call
now for now just to remind you to
download the
slides in the link in the comment
section i left the link there
uh let's see if i can get him back on
try to get too complicated here
it'll probably just be a minute he's
quite good at uh
technology especially for a theorist
let's see if he'll come back on uh
so we will continue because i want to
get to the con to the conformal cyclic
cosmology
and hopefully that will work let me
switch back
oh all right now it's saying call him
when he gets back
let me try to reconnect him i know he's
still there
i do know he has to
reconnect let's see if that will work
hopefully his computer is still working
roger past the event horizon hopefully
not
because that would mean he wouldn't come
back
if he uh doesn't pick up i'll try him by
email
one more time
some reason i think he's gotten kicked
off
let me try one more time here
see if this works yes
hopefully he'll cyclically return to the
magic of skype
all right i'm trying to text him now
bear with me here
okay i'm ringing him
should be there try one more
chance here see now i'm frozen that's
not good
uh can people hear me still out in the
stream
can people still hear me let me know if
you can hear me out there
in the stream
could be a quantum fluctuation very good
one
he's cycled out of the universe
that's a good question can you guys hear
me on the stream
if not let me know
yes you guys can hear me okay good
let's see if i can get him back on
oh maybe there we go ah roger yes can
you hear me
i can hear you all right and jen are you
there too
yeah wow i'm here roger and i can see
roger i can't see you anymore brian you
can't see
me okay don't worry i'm not so important
[Laughter]
hi guys it's great to have you here so
yeah now
now we can all hear it do you guys hear
us on the internet still on
on youtube this is just for a youtube
question do you guys have it
on youtube you see the important thing
is that
if you have full relativity you have
clocks
to measure times and therefore distances
like to send a light signal back and
forth and you can measure distance that
way
so you have accurate clocks and this
comes about because you have mass
now the the opposite side to this
is if you have a state of the world
where you don't have mass
and in the very very remote future all
the black holes have evaporated away
and you've just got photons basically
photons you've got some other things too
but let's forget them
essentially photons running around they
don't have any mass
and therefore the geometry that they
respect is conformal geometry
where you can stretch and squash as long
as the stretch is uniform
you have to stretch as much the swiss
that way and you have to stretch the
time
by the same answers you stretch the
space so the light cones remain
there just as they were now this kind of
geometry
is the geometry of the physics of
masslessness
and in the very remote future the
argument how so the argument goes
you have massless physics maxwell's
equations which describe
electromagnetism and photons if you like
they are completely invariant under
squashing and stretching you can squash
in one place stretch in another place
maximum locations don't even know
anything's happened this applies to
massless things now what about the big
bang
it's just the same but for the opposite
reason
there you have enormous energies things
swishing around an enormous speed
and there the kinetic energy
of particles completely dominates the
mass
so although they do have mass the
particles in the in the very early
universe
the mass the closer you get to the big
bang the more and more
irrelevant the mass becomes and you have
a massless physics
right as you go in the limit back into
the big brand
again you have massless physics
so my argument is that in those two
regions
the dominant physics of the universe or
the dominant geometry of the universe
is conformal geometry con physics of
of massless things so the remote future
is masses because it's got all that
rarified and basically
photons and the big bang where you have
basically massless entities again
the physics is very very similar it
looks completely different because in
one case the big bang you've got
enormous densities and enormous
temperatures
in the remote future you have
ridiculously small
densities and very very cold
very hearts of the big bang very cold in
the remote future
but if you do the squashing the
geometric squashing
in the future and the geometric
stretching of the big bang
the temperature goes up when you squash
the future the temperature goes down
when you stretch the big bang
and there is a match it looks as though
they could easily match
and the argument here is that they do
match so it's a hypothesis
that if you squash down the remote
future
you get something looking like another
big bang
so the picture i have is one where you
think it more like a cylinder
you have the big bangs stretched out and
this
infinity is squashed down and then you
can join that cylinder onto another one
let's have another one before so that
our big bang
was the conformal continuation of the
remote future
of a previous eon i'm calling it so i
say our eon
is big bang to a remote future the next
eon will have our remote future is its
big bang
our big bang was the remote future of
one eon it's big bang was a remote
feature of another one and so on
now i used to go around giving lectures
on this feeling fairly satisfied
nobody will ever be able to disprove it
so i can go on forever giving these
talks
and then irritatingly i had an idea
the idea was when you consider the
black holes before they've evaporated
away particularly ones
which cohabit a cluster of galaxies
our own black hole which just dropped
the nobel prize as well for the
the uh two other people who shared the
nobel prize
for amazing observations which i was
most impressed with when i saw them
but you see these stars going around
this invisible central object
you see they're going these wonderful
orbits i thought gosh kepler was right
well almost
because you see these elliptical orbits
going around and around
although in different different planes
and so on and there's this thing in the
middle
pulling them around in these orbits
wonderful
and so there's evidence for something
like a four million solar mass
black hole in the center both the nobel
prize which it got
but anyway um these black holes
gradually gulp down pretty well
i don't know what proportion of the
stars in the galaxy in the galaxy they
swallowed but probably
most of the stars and millions right
jenna what's the uh
mass at the center is it four million
yeah it's four million for sagittarius a
star
and uh but the one that we took the
picture of in m87
is uh more in the billions of times the
massive sun
much much bigger but because it's 55
million light years away
um it actually subtends about the same
size
on the sky for the telescope as our
smaller black hole
does that's 26 000 light years away
which is to say much closer
ah so it's bigger and further but uh but
was the only other target for the event
horizon telescope project and
and i think that that was the only big
surprise at the reveal i was actually
went to the national press club to see
the reveal i was so excited oh wow
and uh yeah i was and i they had three
badges scientists
journalists and like friends and i think
i took all three
and um and so for me that was the big
surprise was that it was m87
that they took the picture of not
sagittarius a star right
so we're still in pursuit of our of an
image of our own black hole
now when we look at showing the cover of
your book now
uh the black hole survival guide coming
out on tuesday
i'm excited to uh to be described
discussing that with you this coming
tuesday
um yeah looking forward to that so we
had a question for you earlier
uh the astronaut who's on the cover i
presume that's you right um
uh that uh that person who is falling in
on the cover
uh the question is what is the nature of
the
of the time and the experience for such
a person obviously
i don't well they might survive where
they're pictured
just on the outside of the iran horizon
but how long will it take for this
astronaut this comely astronaut to to
get to
his or her ultimate doom right so
the the trick of surviving a black hole
for as long as possible is to fall into
as big a black hole as possible
which seems counterintuitive to people
you would imagine a bigger black hole is
stronger gravitational field but it
would be worse
but actually you notice the curvature
less so imagine you're standing on a
basketball
your two feet are very aware that you're
struggling because they're in different
points on the curvature of the black
hole of the of the basketball
but if you're standing on the earth you
don't really notice right your feet feel
like
they're leveled like they're flat and so
the same concept with a very big black
hole you could sail across the event
horizon
very comfortably uh you could still be
vigorous with youth when you cross the
event horizon you would hardly notice
that you had done so there wouldn't
really be an
obvious experience that would let you
know that you had crossed the event
horizon
so that's one of the beautiful ideas
that einstein came up with which was the
equivalence principle and it has to do
with
but the fact that if space time is
gently curved it should look like
space time and empty in in flat empty
space
but once you cross the event horizon
then you have a very short order before
you
hit the singularity and i'm sorry i
missed some of the previous
conversations so i'm not sure if sir
roger talked about this but
uh but part of uh the nobel prize
winning work
was to prove that at least in the
context of general relativity
the formation of the singularity was
inevitable and not only that
and i sh i saw you showed some of those
light crown pictures
it's in your future right so the
singularity is unavoidable once you've
crossed
you can no more avoid it then you can
avoid a future moment in time
and in a black hole around the size of
our sun which would be a very very small
black hole
um you have much less than a second to
survive
before you get into real trouble if you
make the black hole as big as
m87 like six billion times the mass of
the sun something like that
um you you have that much longer to live
six million times longer to live you
might even be able to eke out a year
if you made the black hole tens of
billions of times the mass of the sun
um so you would have a very
existentially fraught year
as you as you encount you know knew
inevitably that the singularity
was was in your future and there might
even be some trajectories you could rig
where you
you got a little bit longer out of it
but um
but destruction is inevitable
and janna i want to thank you so much
for uh the discussion we're joined now
by another special guest
uh sir eric weinstein is joining us from
uh
somewhere in the ethernet uh eric you're
looking sharp say hello to
jana levin your friend jenna levin and
mine uh and uh jenna
i'm gonna uh yes you can jump off jenna
i wanna just say tune in tuesday we're
gonna have two live streams with janna
one at nine in the morning or so or ten
in the morning
pacific at one pm eastern we're going to
discuss the entirety of this wonderful
new book black hole survival guide
thank you jana have a wonderful weekend
brian thanks for doing this eric great
to see you if bravely and sir roger i
miss you already the last time i saw you
was
last december and it was lovely so be
well everyone thanks for having me on
bye janna
bye bye-bye so eric let me get you
included here you are on live on screen
with sir roger penrose
uh i can't hear you eric can you uh is
your are you muted
i think i think you're muted eric i can
i can't hear you i can hear
let me see okay there we are hello eric
roger great to see you again wanted to
first of all just say mazel tov
on uh getting the recognition um
it's great to see first level top-level
theory back in the game
um and uh just wanted to wish you all
the best in muzzleload
i appreciate that thank you so eric
we're going to be talking in a minute
about uh roger's
conformal cyclic cosmology we just had a
very riveting discussion about
the while curvature hypothesis and
whether or not
we even need a theory of everything
whether or not we even
have reason to believe that there are
singularities in space-time
um uh i said to roger the only instances
they appear
uh are forever shrouded from our view
either in the deep
ancient past of the universe at the at
the origin of the universe our current
uh cycle of the universe if you will or
perhaps
hidden at the core of black holes
forever inaccessible as janna points out
in her book
what say you are singularity's real or
are we just kind of fooling ourselves
and if they're not real
uh why do we need a theory of quantum
gravity
well the first thing i would say is why
waste that question
on me with roger around so let's let's
spin it towards right i want to hear you
guys converse about it yeah so so i
asked roger
i got his opinion but i'm not going to
let i'm not going to tell you what it
was because i don't want to prejudice
your opinion i know how i know how
influential roger is on you and i know
how
how susceptible you are to peer pressure
this is like going into a dojo
and finding anderson silva wants to spar
something like that okay so here we go
um i guess what my read on it and in
part your work sir
is um that this is the key to
understanding that einstein
is really only an effective theory
because i don't believe that those
singularities
will be there in an ultimate theory and
the fact that they're shrouded by
mystery and that they're sort of
protected so that we
sort of can prove that they have to be
there at this level of theory
but on the other hand we can't really
get at them because they are
in fact screened from us in one way or
the other for these two different types
of singularities
is this cert the indication that
einstein
must be effective or could it be in some
sense an ultimate theory in that sector
with these
singularities essential features of
space time itself is this an artifact of
our description
or is this in fact
how the underlying structure likely is
in your opinion and if i need to
rephrase the question and i'd love to
get back to the vile tensor but that
would be the opening
yeah so do you want me to say something
yeah
i mean i guess it's you see when i first
wrote
my papers on this i don't think i tended
to use the word singularity it's just we
don't know what happens at that point
stephen hawking was more um
bold about using the word singularity i
think he meant okay
as far as the classical theory is
concerned we have a singularity so it
gives up at that point
i mean like with the shock wave you
might say the
the theory of laminar flow or whatever
it is and
aerodynamics gives up and you have to
have another theory which describes a
shock wave
um so it's
the argument would be something like
that so general relativity as we know it
would not
apply to what happens but whether
there's any useful
future to to the situation you see you
might say the very
notion of your spacetime and what it
means to say talk about the future
makes no sense at that point so
in the absence of any theory it's
telling us that
our theory of space time general
relativity
gives up at that point it doesn't tell
us if
anything happens i mean what does it
mean anything you
took into that region might get
destroyed and then it doesn't mean
anything to say it continues
you see this was an argument stephen
made
uh which i would have agreed with you
see here's he's an irony you see i would
have agreed with this argument
the big bang you see was the beginning
you may say what was
before the big bang well it's
meaningless to talk about what was
before because the very notion of before
is a space by space-time notion and
therefore it doesn't make any sense to
talk about before the big bang
and i would have said yeah yeah i agree
with that and here am i contradicting
myself
see if you've got a theory then you can
maybe go beyond what you had before
so i i don't agree with the agreement
which means to talk about before the big
bang
i better not because i'm talking about
it
so eric both of you guys have had uh you
know controversial
but provocative new theories that push
the boundaries of the accepted
uh dogma i think in many circles uh you
know
sir roger is sort of a hero or precursor
to some of the work that you're trying
to do now
uh certainly he has for me i want to
turn to his
to his conformal cyclic cosmology which
is my
uh area of expertise such as it is
and and talk about well first uh first
of all what's it like to
be on the avant-garde of physics in a
good way
to work without a tightrope to pursue
things that may not have answers
uh what does that feel like for for you
and what
kind of inspiration do you take
personally from someone like sir roger
well i mean first of all roger is
oddly of course uh singular in our
in our pantheon of living physics heroes
as being
i would say almost everyone would say
the most generative
of our first rank of physicists so that
is
he is less constrained um because
in some sense we're in such a late stage
of physics
that almost every interesting idea is
dead on arrival
and so having any ideas at all that
aren't immediately
dead on arrival is very very difficult
and i think that one of the things that
this nobel prize is going to do
is to send a message to future
generations
that um it's okay to be highly
generative you just have to do it in a
radical and conservative fashion
simultaneously so the math
is extremely um you know it's impeccable
stuff and on the other hand
uh it's also wild stuff i remember
seeing the um
the newsletters from the twister group
back before the internet and
this was like sama's dot we weren't sure
whether people were taking drugs in
oxford or what was going on
but it was florid and it was in its own
language and it was clearly shared by a
group of people
and i i just think you have to think
about roger penrose
as like son raw the great jazz artist
who had a
cult and a commune in his house but also
produced some of the best music around
this is really a throwback to that
tradition it says that it's possible
that roger could have done this if he
wasn't at oxford as well
i would say the one thing that i want to
be really clear about
is also bringing back hardcore geometry
rather than always coming back to the
quantum as the source of weirdness i
think one of the things roger has done
through his artistry
and his ability to depict what can
barely be
seen is to show us the wonder of
geometry that is now underneath
all fundamental physics as post jim
simon's work with
cn yang and so right now we're living in
a world that's purely geometric in which
most of the public discussion
of physical weirdness is about the
quantum and so i think roger renewed
that einsteinian connection and the sort
of simon's yang connection
um by making this relevant but i would
like to get off a technical question
as well of course go for it
you talk a lot about the vile curvature
tensor which is the part that gets
killed when we write down the einstein
field equations it's the part of the
curvature that's sort of
thrown away with the bones in the skin
when we formulate the einstein field
equation
on the other hand it's also weirdly the
part of the curvature
as per the churn theory that contains
most of the topological information
about the nature of the space on which
it resides
what do you make of the fact that we
throw away the portion of curvature
that tells us about the the holed-ness
and the doughnutedness of
potentially space-time but we retain the
portion
that is complementary to that when we
write down the einstein field equations
is that a coincidence does it have
greater significance
well i'm not sure i'm answering your
question but the way i would look at it
is
not in this respect different from
electromagnetism
because there one has the maximal field
and you have the charged sources
so in general relativity the an analogy
according to me it wasn't
perhaps the way other people would look
at it but according to the way i look at
it
you see that the vile curvature is very
analogous to the maxwell
field and when you write it in spinners
it's almost you know just the same
equation you write down
so it's the vial curvature is an analog
of the
electromagnetic field and the richie
curvature
is the analog of the charge so you see
you
you have matter with charged matter
and you that gives you the source for
the maxwell field
and here we have the the richie tensor
which gives you the source to the vowel
field
so it's not so different in that respect
and i think i'm looking at a bit
differently from the way you are
well that's interesting because i
wouldn't have because the
maxwell theory doesn't break into pieces
whereas the
rimani and or einstein theory does break
the curvature into pieces
i don't know i don't think i've ever
heard that
expression of order of differentiation
you see yeah i mean there is a different
order of differentiation because when
you write down the maxwell field
and the charge there is a different
level but the
in the mac in the einstein theory the
ritchie and vile curvature at the same
level you see
people think of them as the as the
curvature tensor
i think was when i wrote these things in
terms of a spinner form which made these
things look more different see the vowel
curvature
is looks you know just four indices
rather than two but it looks awfully
like
natural things i quite agree with you
about putting these curvatures together
while brian is distracted i can actually
take over his podcast and ask you a few
more questions if you don't mind
one question i was curious about is that
in low dimensions
close to where we are and close to the
signature in which we're in which is one
dimension of time and three of space
yeah um
there are lots of weird coincidences we
have a mass
possibility in two spatial and one
temporal dimensions called topological
mass that's not available anywhere else
again
partially due to jim simons but this
time with churn
we've got this cotton tensor that
replaces the vial tensor in some ways in
dimension three
we've got self dual equations in
dimension four
but you'd have to have two dimensions of
time and two of space
so we have all of these weird just miss
um opportunities for our four dimensions
three of space and one of time and we're
surrounded by
exotica there are platypus and uh
an echidna everywhere and weirdly
we're always just out of reach of their
weirdness
to power our universe we could have used
topological mass maybe rather than the
higgs mechanism if we were
one spatial dimension lower do these
practical jokes
suggest to you that they are of any real
importance or are they merely sort of
distractions
uh in a perverse creator's sense of
humor meant to waste our time
and get our hopes up only to dash them
to the ground
i think it's a very subtle question you
see you have these
okay man by the way i'm gonna take a
victory lap like that
yeah that's you got a platypus in there
you got you got a whole host of oddities
in the orey of eric weinstein go on sir
roger sorry
for the plural of a platypus is this or
is it
that's hard if you could figure that out
you'll win the nobel prize in physiology
this turns out to be octopodes topic
well i think an octopuses i thought it
was perfectly legitimate to call them
octopuses
yeah i think it is legitimate but the
the top drawer way of pissing everyone
off is to say oh properties
i was pronouncing as octopodes for years
but please sir continue
and this is a this isn't a kidney okay
nikki no i don't know
i have no idea but anyway these i i was
told that if you if you don't know
enough latin or greek or whatever it is
you can always
use the english way put s on the end um
anyway so uh yeah i mean you've got
these strange creatures
and you have strange creatures in
different dimensions and the trouble is
if you're a mathematician as i
accompany a lot of people who are doing
the mathematics
twisted theory is a good example you see
you do you do it on the wrong signature
inside of you
and you get all sorts of beautiful
things and they prove wonderful theorems
and
all sorts of stuff and you can take more
dimensions too and you could do things
like this
and you can play around with this or you
can do what ed whitton did just change
the signature the
other way around to take two pluses and
two minuses
and then your twisted theory becomes
real and so on okay it might be a nice
trick to play around with for a bit
but it's not physics physics is the
lawrence in signature
and i've always tried to gear what i've
done
to what physics is doing more
and try to not get too pulled away by
mathematical things which may be very
beautiful and
elegant and they do amazing things in
all sorts of different ways but are they
connected with physics deeply not
necessarily
there are a lot of traps you see you can
go guide it off in all sorts of
different directions
mathematically and how connected with
the physical world are they i don't know
i mean they might be in some way i mean
spinners you take spinners and if it's
in louisiana
they have this particular personality
when you
lorenzo in space time when you go to 26
dimensions they're horrendous
so where do you go and do you study well
they study things they have a beauty of
in dimensions but it's not well same
thing but there's certain things in 24
dimensions or seven like there's a
vector cross product in seven dimensions
it doesn't feel like we're very close to
it
so i don't think it tempts us it's a
very weird thing to know about why seven
dimensions would have a vector cross
product
but the fact that we're so close to
these
three and four dimensional coincidences
is
feels very different to me than let's
say the leech lattice
or particular results in 26 dimensions
which are really dimensions
24 results having to do with super
symmetry and things like this
well i don't know i mean mathematics is
full of coincidences
and they may not may or may not have
anything to do with physics so you're
agnostic in some sense
yes yes definitely i would say most of
them don't seem to have messages
and they may some deeper remote physics
that we come to eventually we'll see oh
that's what that's for you see
and then one of the things that i find
fascinating about your work is is that
you
really come across to me as someone
trained as a mathematician
who actually has accepted the yoke of
physics which in some sense is a very
weird thing because most people who
appreciate the beauty of mathematics
find the idea that one particular
physical world should draw our attention
to be kind of coercive imprisoning
it feels artificially small whereas from
the physics side most people who really
want to keep themselves wedded to the
world in which we live
train themselves to resist the siren
song of beautiful mathematics
yeah why are so few people in this
interesting little
overlap between them who are really
concerned about the physical
world and the most beautiful mathematics
which oddly the physical world seems to
know very well
i don't know that i can answer that
question but but you're right it is it
is a puzzling thing
well when i was doing my mathematics
course i
did an undergraduate in mathematics of
course in the uk
that includes a bit of applied
mathematics
so i did know about lagrange equations
and and
that sort of stuff it's been funny sir
roger to see the response on the
on the internet uh reminds me of a quote
by again your
fellow laureate albert einstein
who said that if my theory of relativity
proves to be correct
germany will claim me as a german and
france
and france will claim me as a citizen of
the world however if it proves wrong
france will say i'm german
and german germany will say i'm a jew
and it reminded me of you made a quote
the other day that said something like
to the mathematicians i'm a physicist
into the physicist i'm a mathematician
uh it was kind of uh rhyming with that
and and i wonder
if an alien wakes sir roger up at three
in the morning
you've done all this different work in
math and physics in quantum mechanics
and consciousness and black holes and
singularities
and what's that art and yep absolutely
if this alien comes from another planet
and first of all do you believe aliens
exist
and second of all what do you define
yourself to that alien
aliens oh i see do i believe first do
you believe in aliens and second if if
they do exist and they wake you up
what are you a mathematician a physicist
an artist
a scientist yes oh right i mean i get
away with it by saying a mathematical
physicist
but that's cheating um where it where is
my soul i suppose you might ask is that
sort of what is closest to your heart
very difficult question because of
beauty in the mathematics
but you see it's a hard question
no i was going to say when i was an
undergraduate um
i would a thing that completely bowed me
over was complex analysis
you know it's the way they teach it they
first teach real analysis and they go oh
no
c naught function c one functions three
seventeen functions c
infinity c omega functions the infinity
functions
and they're all different and then you
do complex analysis
once there is differentiable and the
whole lot there in front of your face
complex analysis your contour integral
is amazing all that stuff and i thought
before i knew much physics i thought
gosh wouldn't it be amazing
if the physical world was really driven
by this
wonderful structure and i had a lot of
kind of internal conflict between
complex numbers and combinatorial
physics
because i used to be equally direct
attracted by both ideas
but i think the complex analysis one in
the end
it's just the magic in it what about
higher spaces complex if a complex
appeals to you
i've got these things called quaternions
if quaternions
appeal to you i've got these octonians
and then
eric always loves to go on about uh
clifford algebras
etc what is there a limit is there some
place where the fascination stops for
you
uh when it comes to the bewitching power
of mathematics in the physical world
we swear these two two sides to me um
having their battle and the physics side
probably wins
because i mean the beauty lies on the
mathematics side
but the and the um what would i say the
uh
the drive comes from when eric was on my
show we talked about
uh how how physics classical
you know not classical physics but
classical approach to
solving theoretical uh problems seems to
have
uh stalled in some sense with
breakthroughs like yours
uh coming you know before either eric or
i were born
in the in the 60s that this are we are
we stagnating
in theoretical i should say are you guys
stagnating and theoretically
i'm just a simple experimentalist so i
take no blame
from uptonians i think the split octones
probably do it fundamentally oh really
split
ah what are the split octonians uh can
you describe that either one of you
well you see octonians you've got you've
got eight
generators and you don't have a positive
you have a
well the same thing of quaternions first
you've got a norm which is the sum of
the squares
and it's not a similar thing for
octonions
is split quaternions you would have two
pluses and two minuses
uh let me just think split octonians it
basically it's like you
you have um quaternion you have quit
you have proper quaternions in them
you can find subsystems which are
genuine quaternions
but this is all to do with twisted
theory and palatial twisted theory
you've got these algebras and you've got
the sub-algebras which
looks to me as though they're going to
be things like these
certainly the quaternions i think these
octonians have a role to play
it is it's to do with the signature you
get on twitter's
you see you've got this form which is
hermitian form which has two pluses and
two minuses
when you write that as a real form
you've got four pluses and four minuses
and you can think of that as an
eight-dimensional vector space
and uh the i think the split optonians
have a role to play there but it's
something i
i i might change my mind so i have a
question from a
listener uh miguel uh goes by yeti tears
good friend eric's in mine eric uh and
miguel is wondering uh sir roger penrose
what is the initial inspiration for your
drawings your tilings your
your mercurial sketches that are so um
mesmerizing what what question do you
ask yourself before you sit down to do
art what do you ask yourself
well there's all sorts of things i think
if you look at my
old notebooks you find it's full of
these drawings
and mostly they are where i couldn't
think i could i got stuck you see
and so i just drop draw wide wild things
yeah they're very wild so i came from a
see my grandfather on the my father's
side
was a professional uh
yes he was a very good artist
and my father was one of four brothers
all of them who were distinguished
they were very good artists my father
was a very good artist but his younger
brother roland
became a big figure in the surrealist
movement
so he was in with all the uh
picasso and accents and various people
and
he uh also was one of the originators of
the
institute for contemporary arts in
britain
and started it and uh you know
but my father's interest in art was much
more
um what would you say conservative he
liked to draw realistic
views and things um so my
i departed from that myself i would draw
one thing sometimes i draw realistic
things but it's not
not technically that very interesting so
eric go ahead you come from a family sir
of uh eccentrics and
geniuses and incredibly interesting tree
do you believe that that tree um
really is intrinsically in some sense
tied to the uk
with its toleration for tolerance for
people who weirdly either
conform or wildly not don't conform that
there's a sort of a weird
way in which you can be british and be
respectable and totally non-respectable
at the same time there's some special
sauce
i think you're right there is something
there that's right no certain britain
you know there is a sort of kind of
snobbish
very uh conservative whatever the world
is
um but then the respect for uh
being outrageous in one way or another
yes i think i think there is and
and and being uh there's an obvious word
just just slipped out of my mind here
uh i think outrageous is pretty good
brian he said
i was gonna go with iconoclastic and uh
courageous but yes
i mean there is a respect for that in
britain which you know this is i don't
think you get so much of that in the
states at least
i don't know if it's true now but it
hasn't been
perhaps so much of the past we're trying
to get elon musk to behave so he'll stop
getting those rockets
so sir roger i can't help but ask you
know from the personal side
um how do you think of of stephen now
how how do you think his legacy is
affected by your nobel prizes eric my
friend always says there are
nobel prizes that give prestige to the
to the victor to the one who wins it and
then there's
there are victors who give prestige to
the nobel prize i think eric
you would agree with me that the latter
is true for sir roger
um dude you can't do that he's right
here i know that
that's right well he will indulge me i
i told him you know he endorsed my book
losing the nobel prize and it could have
cost him
his nobel prize you know if they were
smart they they wouldn't have
pushed you down and you he ascended in
the same motion
so sir roger what would how would steven
have reacted uh first of all do you
think that he
should have shared in this prize i mean
this this rule that only three people
can win it is so antiquated and
and ridiculous and and clearly you know
he he deserved it
in a large sense according to a lot of
people where do you come down on that
it's a difficult one you see he always
thought that if they had
if the walking evaporation for small
little tiny black holes had been
observed then he would have got the
nobel prize which maybe he would have
but the thing is i was always doubtful
that little
tiny black holes would be there because
i thought the
big bang had to be very smooth and i
didn't see how they could have come
about
that's not really the point here um
i didn't see that i mean
it as you say you need to get it for
something which
is observed and that seems to be one of
the rules
um and since those
black hole what does he call them the uh
black hole explosions have been seen
but you see maybe they are seen this is
a sort of irony because this is getting
back to ccc
well it's not that yet yeah the hawking
of aberration yes that that is the
that what you might call it the hawking
they're hooking uh
we'll have to wait 10 to 165 years
though to observe it
that's the whole point that's the point
we're seeing them already actually oh
yes okay so let's turn there uh eric
you're welcome to stay in this i want to
talk about
conformal cyclic cosmology and hawking
points
of course yeah go ahead eric absolutely
i had the
um bizarre fortune to have uh
jim watson in my office years ago oh
gosh yes
and um and he was talking about
his uh his relationship with francis who
francis crick would pass and i happened
to be able to bring up
on my screen a clip of
sir francis talking from beyond the
grave as it were
about their collaboration
and i watched jim just get misty that
there was the sense of something
wondrous had had half past and that he
was still in the world to tell the tale
but
francis had gone on and then i said i
accused him i said you know i read your
book very carefully and it really felt
to me like you worked out the hydrogen
bonds
as soon as you found out that the
hydrogen atoms on the nucleotides were
in the wrong place in the textbooks
and from jerry donahue can you admit
that you really
did the double helix and he said
something that i just
i'll never forget and shocked me to my
core he said oh no he said i did the
inside i did the hydrogen bonds
francis did the sugar phosphate backbone
on the outside
and then it was suddenly clear to me
that the greatest collaboration in the
history of science potentially
was a pure collaboration in that you
could see the work of both
individuals in the structure my question
to you is
is there any echo of that in your work
with stephen hawking and i would say
that just
since we're talking about the nobel
prize it's interesting that neither of
you needed the nobel prize to win
universal respect among your peers
and that that is itself a signature of
um of how profound this work is in your
collaboration with stephen hawking is
there a parallel
to saying that you can see the
intertwining
of the two sets of ideas coming together
as one
that's a difficult one i mean it's
certainly he carried the
arguments that i had originally a good
deal further
and you could say get rid of the kosher
surface assumption i had in my
in my theorem and so on and then we
wrote a paper together on this
so certainly there was a big influence
in what he was doing some of the
techniques developed the idea of
koshi horizon which he introduced and
things he did afterwards to do with the
black holes
well these were more or less done with
other people like the work on
on the uh
well it was brandon carter i guess who
well you
you have to go back to to to to um
israel then israel who showed that the
um
stationary solutions with horizons had
to be spherically symmetrical it's quite
curious abe astakar reminded me
of this that there was a lot of
many people held the view that black
holes couldn't exist at that stage
because they there would be so many
which were especially symmetrical so why
could they exist
but it seemed to me that they could
simply radiate away the
multiples and they would end up
certainly symmetrical but then the
work done by started by brandon carter
and then robinson
um not like the other one um
david robinson that's right was there
another one i can't
keep forgetting the names here but they
basically showed that the
the cursed solution was the but there
was a contribution from stephen hawking
which which showed that if they weren't
actually symmetric you see the all the
work they did was assuming
oxy symmetry um and then stephen
showed more or less that they had to be
axismetric if they were going to be
stationary
which is a reasonable good argument so
he did some
at that time i thought that he was doing
the best work of anybody in general
relativity
but that sort of we kind of diverged in
our views
later on and he went off and started
getting too influenced in my view by
string theory and things like that and
also thinking that
black holes and that wasn't yeah we're
going to the story there but he tend to
argue that uh
black holes and white holes were the
same in some sense which seemed to me
to be absurd if you had a classical
object
somehow he thought that the space-time
was
somehow observer-dependent concept
which was not the view i had and so we
we did diverge
well i will say that when you have
people like in let's say in mathematics
uh
jean-pierre ser and alexander grothendig
who came together and diverged
one of the things that i value the most
is the letters that they would write
back and forth
arguing their points not only is the
collaboration
valuable but the fact that you have
people up at that level
yeah who find things on which they can
disagree and do so productively i have
to say that it's both the confluence and
the conflict
that animate these partnerships and
we've seen this from gilbert and
sullivan to lenin mccartney wherever it
is
you know there is an aspect of tension
that actually seems to be very
generative
well certainly our disagreements did
were valuable to me in a sense it
did drive me a certain direction so i
had to think more deeply about things i
was thinking about
but we didn't bring us together in any
way because he
um i don't know but the last
and i did you want i haven't really
talked about ccc properly yes
yes we'll get to that yeah i want to
know what did he think about we'll get
into the details of it in a minute but
what did
steven think about ccc well i'll come to
that you see
because and the answer is going to be i
don't know
i can guess what he said you see um
you know the story i'd more or less
explained about you know about coverage
hypothesis and all that and then i sort
of thought it can't be that it's got to
be
um that you continue the
conformal infinity to to the
stretching out the big bang and and paul
todd my graduate student
i think he was still a graduate student
of mine at that time and he more or less
formulated the condition on the big bang
that it should be continuable as a
conformal manifold so it's the boundary
of a smooth
a smooth boundary thus doesn't quite
give you the var curvature hypothesis it
gives you it's
finite but not zero he didn't want it
zero because it led it to trouble you
into trouble with the equations and so
when i
said i wanted zero because i knew from
theorems
particularly uh um
forgetting people's names now helmut
friedrich who had
shown that with the positive the
positive cosmological consequence it was
a big factor there
and this came from a conversation
i mean my own view of it came from a
conversation i had with
jerry ostriker and i remember i had a
wrong reason for thinking it had to be
zero
which has to do with trista theory and i
had a way of i thought solving the
googly problem that's not going to all
that
which required the cosmological constant
to be zero
and so then i when all this noise about
the
the red redshifts and the supernovae and
seeing well it looks as though there's
an exponential expansion or something
going on
and i think we were going into dinner
some college probably warden or
something and they were jerry ostriker
was there
and i said to him um surely all this
stuff
about the um exponential expansion that
could be just dust couldn't be
and he looked at me and he said look
that's not the point
the point is that you put in the
cosmological constant it makes so many
things fit so much better in cosmology
it's not just the the exponential
expansion observations from the
the reddening of the concealing redshift
of the supernova and all that uh so i
thought okay
you win basically and so i got converted
to the cosmological constant
and this you see made scry the null
infinity not
not null anymore but space like and this
is absolutely crucial
because you need something to fit onto
the big bang which is automatically
space-like
so the fact that the remote future had a
i mean you have a conformal future
conformal future boundary
which was space-like and therefore could
be joined onto a under a big bang
in a plausible way was was a
consequence of this realization
but you see paul had the view that that
you could
describe the via curvature hypothesis in
this way
but if you actually join it on to a
remote future
the vowel coverage has to be zero as i
said helmut friedrich and the theorem
come while i'm showing you this which is
expectation anyway
for other reasons and if this this
causes some problems in
what you do after the big bang
um and it
leads you to actually creation of a very
it really makes dark matter come into
the picture so you have to have dark
matter
so i think it was a good thing so
anyway let's get back to the story yes i
think i'd have described this before
in some in this discussion
but i thought there was no i had this
idea of joining the
big bang into a
normally which seemed to be a plausible
thing to do
maybe just a guess speculation nobody
would ever prove me wrong
and then i had this idea that maybe
collisions between supermassive black
holes
would produce signals which are strong
enough
that you might see if our curvature
would
influence if it would be in a derivative
i forget how many derivatives you need
it's
maybe four or four derivatives i think
before you see
the volatility showing up in the in the
next eon
but you do get an effect which would
affect the
the matter and you would see these rings
in the sky and uh
david spurgle the first person to
try to analyze this and he got
interested in i think he was trying to
disprove it
yes and he got amir hajian to look at it
and they did various things and the way
they were looking at it was a
way that as i learned later they would
never see anything and they didn't see
anything
but later on
came to me and said he'd been looking at
this and he'd been looking at it a
different way
the difference between the two was do
you look at the sky
fixing a radius and seeing whether the
distribution of temperatures
is gaussian over the whole sky and that
was what david berger was suggesting
and i could see that wasn't going to be
any use to me
for to the effects that i was going to
come to the way value was looking at it
was looking
fixing the points and then looking at
the
different radii for each point and you
see that do you see
i mean the way he was doing is
originally wasn't going to convince
anybody and didn't
and so we got into trouble for that
because he was analysis was not
uh in various ways i didn't know
anything about this at the time
but uh he seems to the questions you
could see with this given center
more of these low various rings
if you saw two or three that would be
what i'd expect
because you have superman if you have a
cluster of galaxies then there have been
several collisions
within that same cluster and they would
look like one point
in this in the celestial in the cosmic
background backgrounds
cosmic micro background sky and so you'd
see rings which are concentric
and so that's what vahe looked for and
then
we after a lot of fuss and everything we
seem to see a signal
although nobody seemed to believe us and
then
simultaneous with us in doing it
completely different way
the polish group
polish group christophe meisner pavel
nirovsky
and another poll who was doing the
numerical analysis
and they seem to see evidence for these
rings
too um with about 99.4
uh i'm going to show up on the screen
the analysis for this paper
so let me let me take a step back i'm
going to show on the screen for
listeners
and viewers uh what uh what what sir
roger is talking about let's see that
did not work here
let me let me undo that uh so first of
all i want to go
uh back to uh what this is not so
there's a famous picture of the cosmic
microwave background
with stephen hawking's initials in it s
h
and these are these are cold spots uh of
of significance that's as steven used to
say although eric and my mutual friend
sabine hosenfelder thinks it also stands
for her initials
uh but uh yeah yeah i know you've had
your encounters with her too
and she can be quite quite a quite
delightfully
uh persnickety but uh but this is not
uh looking for stephen hawking's
initials at all we're talking about what
are what you call hawking points
which arise as a natural consequence of
the
uh the persistence of memory of
of black holes surviving in successive
eons
and so yes i thought about these things
before but i didn't face up to them
because the one place in the crossover
from one e on to the next where you
don't get a smooth transition
everywhere else you can write down
differential equations and see what how
would this transition be described
but the supermassive black holes all the
radiation
although you think of it spread out
spread out because it takes so long
to be spread out it's all completely
squashed into a little point
so every supermassive black hole all the
radiation that comes out of that will be
squashed into one point
in the crossover surface probably on our
side smaller than the prank length
i'd have to look at that yeah it doesn't
appear the hawking points don't appear
in in this book in cycles of time you
you were
you're not mentioning that uh in this
book they don't appear in there so
what how did it come about after the
publication
discussions with christoph meisner you
see we were talking
about the rings first and then we're
talking more generally about what other
things might i can't remember all the
conversations because i don't completely
remember talking about the talking
points then
but he says we did later on he then
looked
for little rings and
noticed this very strong signal
that is you saw you look you compared
with a thousand simulations
and out of the you for a particular
size and this is basically
four degrees across in the sky and this
is um
significant because okay you have
here's the crossover surface i have to
fill the right here's the crossover
surface
so walking point you have a black hole
evaporating away and all the radiation
is concentrating that point
all that energy comes through and you
and it has to come through because you
can do integrals to show
that it can't disappear the mass of that
object has to
come through at this point but roger is
that true if it's even if it's not a
singularity
again we have no evidence for singular
what if there are no singularities
someone tells you god
stephen comes down from shamayim from
heaven above
and he asks you uh
roger my buddy my friend there are no
such things as singularities
does that hold true do you would you
abandon the model
it doesn't matter who you do integrals
around it
you see it's like saying is a charge an
infinite density of charge at that point
we don't care you do an integral
gauss integral and you say you've got
the value of the charge from that
integral around the surface
so when you've got this point it's
affect
whether it's a singularity or just a
huge concentration of mass or what have
you
or radiation or something makes very
little difference
i mean maybe it does at some point and
that would be very interesting but for
the moment
all you know is this energy bursts out
and it's it bursts out you don't see it
because you don't see anything
until 380 000 years after the big bang
okay now we come back to jim peebles and
all that sort of work and
last year's nobel prize and the
now there are very good calculations to
tell you
the physics of what goes on from big
bang to last scattering or
or decoupling or don't you want to call
it slightly different places but
more or less the same between that is a
lot of physics which they calculate
this point will spread out a little bit
concentration matter but it will spread
out to
this region which is about four degrees
across in the sky eight times the moon's
light full moon's diameter
and so what you would get is something
like an input
of enormous input of energy into that
little point
it jiggles around it has some kind of a
gaussian behavior
it ends up with a kind of gaussian
distribution of temperature
and the claim we're making is that
you're seeing that gaussian distribution
what they do is they look at a
temperature drop you take rings
the ring and of a certain diameter and
see how the temperature drops from
outside the ring to inside the rim and
then you make
a comparison with
the of the real sky with
thousand simulations and this but
this particular just two little slightly
different diameters you take
you see amongst this 1 000 simulations
you don't see
any of them which have the strength that
you see in the real sky
so the real sky stands out above all of
those and is that true and oh sorry go
ahead
i have a follow-up about polarization
but i'll get to that when he did 10
000 simulations another nine uh
nine thousand and then what used to be a
zero
became a one in one spot and the other
one it became a two
that tells you you just do a little
bit of statistic tells you the big
confidence level this is a real effect
in the real sky
is 99.98
so this is a much stronger signal than
we saw with the win
eric i don't know how much you've looked
at this uh at this cosmological model
but um
what what are your impressions about it
from uh educated lay person
you're shaking i can't hear you you're
muted still i think
he's shaking his head okay all right so
i've seen the international symbol for
don't drag me into this i don't want to
say
uh let's see roger could you move a
little closer to the camera or
or tilt it down a little bit so i have a
paper that i'm showing on the sky
on the sky on the screen uh from friends
of mine on the plonk team
and they show the plots that you're
talking about with significant
um hawking points plotted and they make
a couple of
cases uh they talk about how these
hawking points
would evolve or or behave depending on
whether or not
you looked at them both statistically
through the all the planck data that's
available now in 2018
which includes multi-frequency and
polarization
so the first obvious thing that i would
do uh is look at these in polarization
because that is more than just doubling
the information in some sense it's it's
sort of squaring the amount of
information or more
uh so have you looked at it and does the
significance hold up
because according to them it goes down
but but what have you learned
it looks at it with different things and
they also looked at the plankton
of the wmap data what i found most
not most convincing but very convincing
is that if you look at you see there's a
different analysis that dan
and did to look for where these points
are
you see the analysis that was done in
the paper
doesn't locate the points at all it's
just an overall analysis for the entire
sky
and this is where these confidence
levels come from it doesn't tell you
where they are
but dan anne looked specifically for
points where the
intensity increased at this sort of
level and he found
quite a few points now i'm not sure that
i believe all of them
what i do tend to believe is that the
strongest the five
strongest points in the
in the planck data if you look in the
wmap data
they're all there in exactly the same
spots
there's a sixth one in the w map which
is pretty strong
when you go back and look at the plant
and you see it's there too it's not one
of the
five strongest or the six strongest but
it's there so those six points
which you see in both maps
i think the case is very strong that
they are what we would call hawking
points
now ab initio if you took us you know a
a cosmological model
a black hole density these come from
supermassive black holes not unlike the
ones at the center of the milky way m87
and elsewhere
knowing that there are many many of such
supermassive black holes perhaps one at
the center of every
supermassive or massive cluster of
galaxies why wouldn't you see more than
literally we could count on one hand
two reasons one is you see a very small
proportion of them
you see only the ones which are just at
our particle horizon
you see where our past light cone goes
it hits the surface there all have lots
of them in the middle you don't see any
of them
the only you see with the colliding ones
with the rings you do see ones in the
middle
but here you only see the ones just on
the edge
so it's a very small proportion of all
the black holes
these are only the very big ones i think
you would see a lot more than the ones
we've seen
these are only the big ones um
i would think a dedicated analysis of
some sort
you might have to have another satellite
i don't know
you ought to be able to see a lot more i
think we're only seeing the strongest
ones
which we happen to catch which are just
on that little tiny
um rim what you little little tiny
surface
which is uh where are just where our
particle horizon happens to be
so that's that's the reason you don't
see lots more i wouldn't expect i'm
lucky probably to see those ones as
strong as we do in fact it needs working
out exactly how big they are
i have a way of doing it which we
haven't actually worked out i've tried
to get christoph to look at it
he tries to get me to be more specific
about how to do it
well that brings up another question
from one of my listeners in india who
asks for a young student such as himself
or herself uh what what kind of
directions in cosmology if you were
starting off again
as as a young graduate student with a
with a bright mind and
eager disposition what would you
recommend that somebody pursue
i think there are a lot of problems a
lot of questions to answer here
there are questions of particle physics
to answer what are the error bombs now
when i say erebon
that is a dark matter particle now it
doesn't matter
according to the scheme dark matter
should be created at the big bang and
then gradually decay away
it's created through the equations you
see the equations only work
at the crossover from eon to eon if you
introduce a dark matter the dominant
material in the universe
then now it has to have a half-life
of something like 10 to the 11 years so
we're just about
seeing the ones decaying now but since
the
majority of the matter in the universe
is dark matter
you probably should see quite a lot of
these decades do you actually see them
what do they decay into now i consider
their decay into into gravitational
signals
so probably these are signals you might
pick up in gravitational wave detectors
it needs a lot more work
to work out what on earth these signals
are like i don't know what they're like
i just think they should be
gravitational signals
but another thing that persists you know
the the persistence of memory
as carl sagan used to say my my friend
and miniature here here's uh
here's a carl sagan right there um he
used to call it the pursuit really
related to
um things that survive time especially
things like
your wonderful books and i'm trying to
work with our friend uh
um let's see i had a little glitch right
here but in the
the matrix didn't like when i said uh
lord eric weinstein or that he is going
to write a book but you are going to
write a book eric
but carl sagan said a book is proof that
human beings can work magic
i think black holes are kind of magical
i also think that magnetic fields are
kind of magical
and is it not possible is it not
possible for for magnetic fields to make
it through
the simulation yeah so so can you talk
about that
absolutely no this is in fact i was
going to ask you that question
very interesting no you see a black
magnetic field
i mean this is really paul todd again
who
well he was sitting next to somebody i
can't remember it was a question that
came up about
primordial magnetic fields and things
like that which seem to be you get these
things in voids and where do they come
from themselves yes it's fascinating so
paul asked me you say well what about
magnetic fuels and electric clusters
did they come through and i said yeah
sure just electromagnetism they come
through like
like like a beam of light definitely
so you should see them where should you
see them
you should see them where you used to
have a cluster of galaxies presumably
that's where they would be strongest
where are they they're where their
hawking points are
so you i would guess
you ought to see primordial magnetic
fields
around talking points and that's
something we can test and you and i have
talked
about collaborating uh as well on this
phenomenon
um and uh one of my uh actually my post
one of my colleagues is a postdoctoral
scholar here
uh dr grant tepley formerly of caltech
and currently of uc san diego works in
the simon's observatory
he wants to know if you've looked at uh
if you've looked at the cold spot
there's this
anomalous cold spot not a hot spot like
a hawking point would be
but a cold spot and that's a subject of
great interest because it's
anomalous at the many many sigma level
of significance what do you think about
cold spots in the theory of conformal
cyclic cosmology
this is only a guess so i i'm not i
think
people have told me where it is but i
think it is
fairly close to you see one of the most
striking pictures you get
and i don't know if you've got that one
up it's a picture that vahe
made of the planck data it's the paper
that we wrote together on the fermi
paradox can you find that paper yes i'm
gonna uh
i'll look that up um but keep keep
describing it it'll take me a second to
what he plotted was in the plaque data
centers of
low variance rings and you only count
them if you see at least three
concentric rings
these three concentric rings that's
right there may be more than three but
no less than three and
they are color coded now here's where i
get confused
they're color coded according to the
temperature the average temperature
now because of two backwardnesses the
red ones are actually the very distant
ones
in the theory the color coding is that
the red ones are the hot ones
and so you might think of them as blue
but they're also
in ccc it goes the other way around that
say the distance signals
are the blue are the blue shifted ones
because the signal is coming towards us
and therefore it's blue shifted you
won't see them if it's going away from
us
whereas the near ones you see them if
it's going away from us that's the way
the geometry works
so that the there's a big splodge
the biggest splodge in the picture if
you see if you see have you got the
picture up there i'm trying it's a
very low resolution the picture that i
have but um but keep going
there's a picture where you see
color-coded
multiple significance levels for yes
i'll show that yeah
and you see on the bottom sort of
you see there's a the middle galactic
plane is removed so there's a whole
region which is cut out
but then points which are not in the
removed region
even if the circles intersect the
removed region they are included in this
scheme
and the color coding is depending on
according to me how distant they are so
if you see red ones
they are blue shifted and therefore
distant i always get myself confused
though because
that's the right way around but the
point is the cold spot it could be
it could be essentially a sign
convention in the way that he's making
the plots in
other words or cold part well there is a
convention which i have to come to as a
confused people
let me get to that there's a cold spot i
think is close to the red splodge
well with a huge number of sources
outside our
particle horizon so we don't directly
see the galaxies
however we do see according to this
the collisions between supermassive
black holes in the galaxies
and so those that that galactic super
duper cluster
is only evidenced by the collisions
between the black holes
in the in that super duper cluster so
what i'm claiming
is that there is a super or was is the
right word i guess
a super massive black hole cluster
a super massive cluster let's say of of
galaxies presumably with large
very large numbers of supermassive black
holes running into each other and
producing
this huge red conglomeration now i'm
just this is
not off the top of my head because i
thought of it before but it was on top
of the top of my head then too maybe
this huge density of
galactic and you see this in homogeneity
there
other people have to explain it somehow
anyway it's there
in this analysis now what it ex what it
indicates is a question for other people
but we claim
it is evidence of a supermassive
a super duper i'll call it cluster of
galaxies
where you are seeing the collisions of
the galaxies the
gravitational wave signals from those
collisions and they're coming through
now that if that was a huge
density of material then the material
around it
would be attracted towards it now that
could mean that material that we see
within our
is to some extent moving away from us
and therefore colder so if the cold spot
is somewhere around there
that's a possible evidence from these
signals
that the uniform that the universe is
not merely so homogeneous
and isotropic as people think
this not only from i think very
strikingly from that picture i'm trying
to guide you to in value
you see the color very brightly colored
one i think it's 1b
or something you can't remember
numbering
yeah i'm showing them all there's
several of them and they depend on
uh which quadrant of the galaxy one is
looking at
um but i know you have an appointment
coming up
soon sir roger so i want to be
respectful of your time
and thank you you'll be soon picking up
uh
a special kind of of of coal of hot spot
when you journey and make the journey
although it's gonna be virtual right
you're not gonna be in person
for the nobel uh the nobel banquet is
not taking place this year they don't
even know what's going on
let alone me now they want me to be
at the swedish embassy see this concert
there's a building that's swedish out of
sweden in london
where i have to go which is i'm not sure
if it's the swedish embassy
but it's it's part of the swedish
embassy complex
and uh i think they will the
the uh event will take place they're
probably everybody with masks on yes
and i think they may give me a medal of
some sort then i knew it was uh i knew
they would find a way to punish you for
leaving in comium on my
fair book uh somehow and it looks like
2020 has conspired to make that come
true
i want to uh thank you sir roger and my
friend eric eric
any final words for our beloved friend
uh just congratulations and if you have
any thoughts
about where you think
young people younger than myself should
be charging off
i hope you will make them known to the
field because i think that your voice
newly empowered as it were by this shiny
disc
is going to make a huge difference in
renewing the field i hope
i want something clarified though before
before yes yes i
i think i'm working on it
there are some thoughts about that
absolutely um yes indeed
well you may know about this this thing
called the penrose institute which has
it may have a revival yeah yes we're
hoping to establish that here
deepen our connections between the
arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
and the penrose institute which will be
located here uh
let me ask you a question which is very
critical to this
question i understand from what you've
just been saying
if i interpret this right that the
telescopes or whatever is it chimney or
yes we'll have telescopes in chile and
at the south paul antarctica
oh both oh that's good now presumably
you are you're able to
pinpoint magnetic fields is that the
question well rather than just
the issue yeah the issue of primordial
magnetic fields is a very rich one
because as you mentioned
we have evidence for magnetic fields on
all scales from the human being scale to
the planetary scale to the galaxy
to the cluster scale tens of megaparsecs
across but we have no evidence
for an uncollapsed magnetic field a
magnetic field not associated with some
gravitationally bound structure
one of the goals of the simon's
observatory is to do just that to look
for primordial magnetic field signatures
which will reveal themselves at high
resolution
with our large aperture telescope the
led six meter diameter telescope of the
simon's observatory is building
where they are it's not just an overall
we're gonna survey a very large fraction
of the sky tens and tens of percent
not as much as plank but with much
higher resolution much higher
precision and much higher accuracy in
terms of calibration for
planck was not designed and neither was
wmap it could do polarization
but in terms of doing it you have to
look for very subtle experimental
effects that can systematically
contaminate
but what's so cute roger and you'll
appreciate your friend jim simons in
mine
uh he is convinced that there is a
signature of churn simon's
birefringence cosmic birefringence that
we're also looking for there was
actually a claim of
evidence for it that just came out uh
published by
uh scientists in in japan and in uh and
in germany
and uh but the issue is uh you get it
for free if you search for
primordial magnetic fields which
presumably could confirm or
possibly you know this as well as i do
refute
our own favorite hypotheses it could be
true that we discover
that there are no hawking points that's
a possibility but what's so interesting
is we get for free constraints
on lorentz violation on parity violation
and
on things exotic physics scalar fields
etc
uh called cosmic birefringence and so uh
we get it for free we're gonna learn a
tremendous amount about this we'll be
able to test it
and who knows you you and you and jim
might get a second one you might be the
second person
ever to get a a non-chocolate gelt uh
nobel prize
no no the other people have had to do
yes that's true oh yes yes but in
physics only one right
only on the uh bardeen right oh yeah
says
yes that's right yes um
so i want to thank you i want to remind
people in the into the impossible family
that we're going to be doing a live
stream with adam reese
uh uh sir rogers co-laureate we're doing
a live stream with adam reese janna
levin
wendy friedman david spurgle who you
mentioned and
uh and myself coming up this tuesday
night we're doing live star gazing
it's the 30th birthday of the hubble
telescope sir roger
and it's the 20th birthday of the
international space station
so our partners and friends in wyoming
stargazing we're going to use
huge telescopes to recreate the 1920s
kurdish shapley debate that concerned
the size of the universe so that's
happening tuesday night this coming
tuesday the 10th of november
at 6 pm eastern time i hope you guys
will join uh in what continues to be a
wonderful year of
pandemic podcasting sir roger penrose i
want to thank you so much uh i'm sorry i
kept you so long
i i can't resist it's it's too difficult
when you have good friends
to chat with i wish you all the best
congratulations a hardy mazel tov as we
say
and uh and all the best roger be well be
healthy and continue to do great work
and inspire
billions around the world thank you so
much yes
bye gentlemen goodbye